à foncine l'eau derrière le nom d'une
chaîne de supermarchés connu affiché sur
la devanture se cache l'une des plus
vieilles coopérative alimentaire de la
région elle a pour nom espérances et
c'est là que nous retrouvons amélie doué
bonjour à tous et bienvenue à l'épicerie
seller et les me dit bonjour simone
bonjour qu'est ce qu'on mange à midi
simone de l'entrecôte réservé par
jean-françois alors ça c'est
exceptionnel ici nous sommes dans une
épicerie coopérative c'est à dire que on
fait les courses limite pour vous voila
voila on réserve mes aliments
vous venez ici puis combien de temps aux
depuis longtemps c'est j'ai déjà un
compte ouvert depuis mes parents donc je
continue
qu'est ce qui vous plaît l'ambiance le
magasin on trouve tout on commande nous
réserve
tout le monde nous accueille avec le
sourire vous êtes à foncine le haut et
vous n'avez pas besoin de descendre à
champagnole ou chez paou pour obtenir
des cheveux francine disant je suis des
planches en montagne et je suis à dix
kilomètres de foncine donc ces pratiques
et voilà et il ya tout ce qu'il faut et
ya tout ce qu'il faut
mots et les tarifs les tarifs sont à peu
près paraît que les grandes surfaces
donc vous êtes sociétaire de cette
équipe voilà et vous avez le droit à une
petite ristourne en fin d'année
paraît-il ristourne au mois de octobre
novembre
ça se passe comment très bien j'arrive
au mois d'octobre on me dit tiens tu as
50 60 euros de réduction et ça c'est
parce que vous avez été une bonne
consommatrices voilà plus on achète plus
on a des réunions on a des réductions
bon je vous remercie simone moi je vais
aller faire un petit tour de l'eau de
l'autre côté de la boutique pour un
petit peu mieux comprendre comment ça
fonctionne voilà c'est jacky qui est
président ici c'est une coopérative une
épicerie coopérative ça existe depuis
1909 et depuis 1909
on peut donc venir à foncine le haut
acheter tout ce qu'on veut et jacques il
s'est notamment grâce au fonctionnement
de cette épicerie coopérative absolument
donc en 1909 là
à la coopérative a été fondée par des
ouvriers diamantaire qui travaillait
dans une usine à l'entrée du pays
sur les conseils de leurs homologues de
saint claude qui allait fonder la leurs
quelques dizaines d'années auparavant
donc cette société avait été développé
pour proposer des produits de première
nécessité avait à des prix attractifs
et puis compétitif et
on va dire dans un but de desservir la
les pays alentour l e la commune et ça
c'est à perdurer
ça a perduré et on a développé
l'ensemble des acteurs ont développé le
magasin pour qu'on ait aujourd'hui une
surface de vente de 300 mètres carrés
qui a évolué au fil des années les
clients sont des sociétaires ils sont à
peu près 600 à être adhérent de votre
période et à 600 clients qui ont acheté
une action
oui et ce sont les réels propriétaires
du magasin et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
un petit peu la loi ils décident ce
qu'ils veulent manger ils font leur
petit comment voilà ils font leurs
commandes ils ont des desiderata qu'on
essaye de satisfaits et puis ben ils
nous demandent ce que ce qu'il souhaite
obtenir au niveau des magasins est dans
l'instant où on peut les servir
on le fait volontiers et c'est aussi ça
qui est important ici c'est leur
relationnel avec le client c'est pas
juste un magasin quand même exact exact
les gens viennent ici un tue un petit
peu pour l'information pour le plaisir
de discuter pour avoir voilà la
convivialité et c'est ce qu'on souhaite
garder dans les années à venir alors
président je vous emmène avec moi mais
on va rejoindre les deux responsables du
magasin les responsables c'est jean
françois et philippe bonjour alors vous
vous êtes là au quotidien et votre votre
mission c'est d'achalander ce magasin
mais philippe vous vous êtes là depuis
tout à fait c'est vraiment un choix vous
n'êtes pas un simple vendeur non j'ai
cherché du travail en 1988 c'est mon
premier travail je suis arrivé ici puis
ça m'a plu j'ai fait des tournées
c'est ce qui m'a plu derrière au départ
et puis ben je suis resté vide parce que
je me plais très bien ici vous échanger
avec les gens et parlez nous de cette
tournée ça c'est très important dans
dans une région comme foncine-le-haut
allait encore à la rencontre des clients
tout à fait on a beaucoup de personnes
âgées qui
ils n'ont pas les moyens de se déplacer
ou qu'elles sont très très heureuse de
nous voir arriver devant la maison où on
s'arrête devant chaque maison
jean-françois vous vous continuez les
tournées encore aujourd'hui vous faites
même les livraisons qui n'ont rien à
voir avec l'épicerie oui tout à fait on
s'attelle blanc mâle vendredi c'est vous
à châtel blanc vous pouvez même amené de
la pharmacie dans la pharmacie c'est au
magasin après on peut la montée en
tournée si jamais a besoin mais c'est au
magasin qui nous pose la pharmacie et
puis des fois il ya des petits détours
dans la tournée il faut s'attarder avec
un les clients oui on s'arrête pour voir
un petit verre avec nous avec nos
clients préférés voilà c'est le service
après vente
jean-françois je vous en fait est ce que
vous vous êtes presque né ici
ma mère a fait 40 ans ici donc je suis
un peu ici mon grand père était
détournée bien avant aussi fait beaucoup
d'amis ici aussi
et donc c'était logique que vous
travaillez et vous haussez lips est
pareil vous n'imaginez pas travailler
ailleurs on est vraiment dans le
relationnel aux clients à bord
aujourd'hui tout à fait non je me
verrais pas partir dans un supermarché
dans notre magasin en tout cas ils ont
l'air exigent aux clients ils sont
exigeants mais bon on fait tout pour les
on fait tout pour que pour les pour les
satisfaire pardon et puis ça se passe
bien ils sont exigeants mais sont très
sympas on le voit vous êtes des salariés
heureux un président heureux et ça c'est
le fonctionnement de cette coopérative
alimentaire ici à foncine le haut elle
est ouverte 7 jours sur 7 ça c'est un
exploit
ça existe depuis 1909 et ils sont 600
actionnaires mais il n'y a aucune
redevance us de la petite ristourne à la
fin de l'année merci beaucoup amélie